- Let's just grind,
build these events and
make money
10,000 here. 30,000 there.
Let's save it.
Let's fucking until
we're 30, let's make a pact.
Everybody in.
'Til we're 30.
Save, save, save, shit collapses
you're buying million-dollar
homes for a $100,000.
Catch the next swing, game over.
And if I could tell you as when
you're 37-year-old dude you just
feel just as much like a
22-year-old dude and when you're
a 37-year-old dude
with millions of dollars,
all those things
you wanted to do
in your 20s and 30s,
you can catch up.
("Monday To Monday" by Saba)
Saba, I've been telling you.
So today is the day
we head to my house for
the fantasy baseball
draft. Super excited.
Couple quick morning
meetings and then away we go.
("Leaving" by JayTwo)
Time fucking Square.
See ya.
And not be in a
place where, if it's free,
it's not on me. Right?
I think the best thing I can do
to empower people is actually
show people how to do it and
then do it and motivate them to
do it and make them think.
A lot of my behavior is
to make kids think I'm cool.
Lot of reasons I do what I do is
because I know if they think I'm
cool they're more
likely to do what I do.
And then I'm able to suck out,
like if I let the scam artists
be the cool ones then
they're gonna do that.
But if I'm even cooler than
them then they'll do what I do.
The right way.
So like, see where I'm going?
If you're really
passionate about helping people,
you're not gonna do it in
this model 'cause you're gonna
attract the
people that can't do.
Really trying to help my
community but I'm asking nothing
from them in return.
I'm not charging
them and I have a much
bigger reach
than everybody else.
- [Man] I think one of
the biggest things--
- So it's easy for me
to give the advice 'cause
I'm not full of shit, right?
I'm telling you what I'm doing
and the cool part is you guys
know I'm doing it.
Like you know how I look
different than people that want
to sell the $1,000
course version of it.
- [Man 2] I respect
your opinion.
- I mean it's just real.
- Yeah.
- It's just super real.
- [Man 2] Yeah.
- And I know that I'll
be here in 2022 and 2029 and
2041 and the others won't.
Not because I'm a genius but
because I study what's
always happened in life.
And so, to me, I've now in this
weird position I've found myself
is like am in the place is like
passionate to help both versions
of this vibe
because I especially can
help the vibe that's
high energy and you
choose what you want to look at.
The biggest reason I don't have
way more followers is because
people come in and they take
themselves out immediately
'cause they don't
want to face my truth.
They want to go follow people
that put money on beds and take
a photo of it.
You know, they
don't want to deal with
what I'm talking about.
But there's a big difference.
This is not what those
people's companies look like.
They look like rented
houses and fancy places.
There's a big difference, man.
And you have to understand
the economy's been good, too.
This is all spurred up to good.
They die soon.
So, I'm just
trying to give you really,
really good advice.
I want you guys to win.
You know what?
If nothing else it gives you
something else to think about as
you're playing chess.
You know?
Cool.
- [Man 3] Thanks, Gary.
- [Gary] Take care.
- [Woman] Gary,
these are for you.
- Yes! Thank you. I love it.
See you later, James.
("Delusion" by JayTwo)
- Mr. Vaynerchuk.
- [Gary] Yes?
- Nice to meet you.
- [Gary] Nice to meet you, man.
- [Man 3] I'm actually
on my way to meet Sean.
- Good luck.
Alright guys,
trying to make a DailyVee.
I'll make it a little
meaty for you 'cause I know
it's a short day.
Short day because I'm
going to a weekend where
we're doing fantasy baseball.
20 homies coming in.
We've been
doing it for 20 years.
Fantasy baseball
draft is on Sunday.
We've never done this before.
Actually, seven or eight years
ago we went to Atlantic City but
people coming this
afternoon to my house.
People coming in tomorrow
morning and then Sunday we draft
so I'm super excited.
Super important
to have two, three,
four, five, six things in your
lives that are escapism that
don't matter but matter so much.
I care more about fantasy
baseball draft and the Jets than
I do about any account that
I work with at VaynerMedia and
I think you need to have
that balance of extremism when
you're this intense, this on.
So if you're somebody like me,
make sure you find three or four
things that don't matter at
all that create that balance.
That place where you can dump
all the intensity of your life
into and that's what this
weekend's gonna be for me.
So that's a little fun fact.
Another quick little fun fact
is that been having some really
awesome meetings where it's
getting very obvious to me that
this world we all
live in is just very real.
This is it.
This is the remote
control of our society.
If you are not thinking about,
and I'll leave it with this,
this is the punchline.
Whatever you're
trying to achieve,
become an artist,
become a t-shirt entrepreneur,
become a politician,
become a real estate mogul,
become a video super star,
become an actress,
an NBA player,
stick with me here.
Whatever you're
doing, politician,
selling coconut water,
whatever you're doing if all,
all of your strategic
energy isn't against how do I
communicate that
through this device and
the five to seven channels.
Facebook, Twitter,
Instagram, Snapchat,
LinkedIn.
The channels that
live on that world,
how do I do that in this
device and on those channels?
That's it.
Pot-committed, chips in and how
do I become a great storyteller
contextually in
all of them. Right?
iTunes podcast or YouTube
videos or articles on my blog or
Medium, Google Adwords,
Facebook ads,
Snapchat filter marketplace,
influencer marketing.
Regardless of what
you're trying to accomplish,
you've got to tell
the world about it.
This is now the world.
If you're not betting
on this, you're finished.
on this, you're finished,
if you're not betting on this.
You're finished.
- [Gary on Phone] I don't think
you have to fully abandon them.
- [Woman on Phone] Yeah.
- [Gary on Phone]
But you need to find,
you need to make sure that the
cadence of the amount of hours
you put in--
- Intense.
- [Woman on Phone] Yeah.
- [Gary on Phone] You
know and you also have
your whole life to live.
- [Woman on Phone] Yeah.
- [Gary on Phone] I don't know
what your family situation is
but like...
- My content's so deep.
- [Other Tyler] (laughs) I know.
- It's so raw.
It's so like unwavering.
Makes sense why it works.
- [Other Tyler] There's
just like no
sugar on top of anything.
It's just is what it is.
- It's so intense.
It's the only way to win.
It's got to win.
You can't, you can't hedge.
Every hedge
creates a vulnerability.
Dude, you should
learn YouTube hacking.
- [Other Tyler] I know.
- Do it.
I mean what are
you here for, right?
If you become great at it and
you decide to do things with me,
you'll be more valuable to me.
If you don't,
it'll be good for you.
- [Other Tyler] Yeah.
- Like an hour a night.
That's what's cool because
then you can be more valuable to
yourself and to us.
- [Other Tyler] Yeah.
- Just a win-win situation.
But it's work.
- [Other Tyler] Yeah.
- Start learning
how to, but you know?
- [Other Tyler] Yeah.
- Also, but it also may make
you film in a way differently.
- [Other Tyler] Yeah, for sure.
Okay.
- It's worthwhile.
Listen, that'd be like hey
Gary but even just trying for a
couple of...
- [Other Tyler] Yeah. Taste it.
- Months. Yeah, exactly.
Mhmmm.
- [Other Tyler] I would
also at some point,
like, maybe later this year,
like to actually have a sit down
drink with you or something
like that and have a real talk.
- Don't wait.
Don't wait that long.
- [Other Tyler] Cool.
- Let's do it in
the next 60 days.
- [Other Tyler] Done.
- What do you want to
jam about? Like strategy?
- [Other Tyler] Yeah,
I just want to chat.
- Yeah.
- [Other Tyler] I feel like so
much of our interaction is just
like running around.
- I'm in, brother.
Thrilled to do it.
- [Other Tyler] Talking
like only strategic stuff.
- Thrilled do it.
- [Other Tyler] Cool.
- Would love to.
Get to learn a lot
by watching me, huh?
- [Other Tyler] Yeah.
- How the fuck does it scale?
It's so interesting, right?
- [Other Tyler] Yeah.
And it's weird--
- What's the biggest
thing you've learned?
- [Other Tyler] (sighs)
I don't know.
There's a lot.
(Gary laughs) Just like I don't
waste a fucking second any more.
Just like constant in motion.
- It's crazy, right?
- [Other Tyler] Yeah.
- It's cool.
That's a good way
to end the episode.
Let everybody hear that.
I'm serious.
- [Other Tyler] Cool.
("Leaving" by JayTwo)